Quintessa!
The winner is...
Get it outta here!
that's true -- whoever wrote this on the card, you’re fired!
because global warming is NOT a joke!
You get a 10 over here and a 9.5,
None of them really made me happy.
Both of yours were mildly offensive.
Oh man.
I'd still fall for you.
Even if there wasn't any gravity on Earth,
I would charge you rent.
You spend so much time on my mind,
If you were a book, I'd check you out.
You're so hot, you must be the reason for global warming.
Because I need your name and number.
Do you have a jersey?
If you were an Instagram photo, I'd like you.
It's like the jay-z album.
444. You get a 444.
Now I can tell my friends that I've been touched by an angel.
Kiki, would you grab me arm?
Either way we're going to be together.
Heads I'm yours, tails your mine.
You guys am i dumb? Okay tell me what this means:
That gets a minus 2
That was so good.
Terrible! I thought that was good.
No? Then please start?
I’m sorry, were you talking to me?
I'd give that like a 399. These are really high scores.
Okay, that was a good one.
I’m over here like struggling.
Why are you so good at this.
I think i just found the treasure.
Was there a rainbow today?
exclamation mark, you get a 333.
I like that one! you get a star, a moon,
you'd be what they call fine print.
If you were the words on a page,
50.
Because I'm feeling a connection.
Is your name wifi?
Math was not my thing so i'm gonna say 110 - 2.
Because you're looking right.
Are you a 90 degree angle?
because 4 is my favorite number and that was awesome.
Okay that was a 444,
Are you part beaver because DAMN.
Ok.
Give it to me!
Yes, and this is Charm Battle.
and we are from Trinkets on Netflix.
I'm Brianna,
Hey I'm Kiana,
Hey I'm Quintessa,
Terrible! I thought that was good.
Were you talking to me? No? Then please start?